el museo de Cartago de túnez patrimonio
Mundial de la UNESCO alberga tres mil
años de historia fenicia púnica romana
bizantina cristiana y musulmana un
testimonio del diverso pasado cultural y
religioso de la región
[Música]
la edición 14 de la semana de la moda de
túnez acoge este acontecimiento
humanitario primera joya descubierta una
colección realizada a partir de residuos
plásticos marinos reciclados
diseña esta colección en torno a dos
ideas principales
en primer lugar el mar Y en segundo
lugar Algunos detalles metálicos y
dorados en la ropa
que recuerdan a la armadura de Aníbal
y también hay un bordado especial que
representa la Diosa de la
la diosa de Cartago tanita
ahí lo tienes es una parte de la
historia de túnez que quería destacar
la marca Uta es el fruto de una
colaboración entre industriales locales
y el centro internacional de altos
estudios agronómicos mediterráneos que
ayuda entre otras cosas gracias a los
capitales europeos a la descontaminación
del archipiélago de quererte
la idea era ver cómo se podía poner en
marcha y estructurar una cadena que
permitiera recoger este plástico y
tratarlo para reutilizarlo en productos
de alto valor añadido
que permitieran remunerar bien a los
recolectores quienes trabajan en
condiciones a menudo muy difíciles y
cuyos ingresos son muy escasos
que desde hace 15 años dirige la semana
de la moda de túnez
Por qué este compromiso para salvar el
planeta se trata de dejar a las
generaciones futuras un planeta limpio
con la ayuda de mi hijo de tres años
llamé a esta colección ota es una
referencia a mi compromiso También se
trata de dejar a mi hijo un mundo mejor
y más limpio
otro descubrimiento es la joven
diseñadora portuguesa Joana maltés que
estudió en la escuela de diseño de
Lisboa
me gusta hacer piezas escultóricas
Normalmente me inspiro en esculturas me
gusta aprovechar las formas me gusta
trabajar los tejidos y la manipulación
de las telas
es impresión 3D esos no no son esos esto
es trabajo manual antiguo me gusta usar
las manos para esto
otro talento prometedor Harumi 18 años
le encanta contar historias a través de
sus colecciones y tiene grandes
ambiciones para su país
el gobierno tiene que invertir en los
jóvenes en el arte en los artistas
porque ese es el futuro
solo se puede cambiar un país cambiando
la mentalidad
Así es como se influye en la gente la
gente tiene hay que respetar lo que
hacemos
lo que intentamos transmitir al mundo
porque tenemos mucha energía mucho
entusiasmo solo tienen que confiar en
nosotros
era estilista en París con Tomás después
de una relación tóxica con su marido
coge el toro por los cuernos y decide
montar su propia casa de costura dándole
un toque moderno a la fruta blusa la
tradicional túnica nupcial tunecina y la
marca lleva 16 años en el mercado Sí así
es
y en algún momento hubo una iluminación
en realidad hubo un momento de verdadera
Claridad en 2014
en 2014 pensé después de todo este
tiempo tienes que hacer lo que realmente
quieres hacer
realmente no importaba lo que pensara la
gente
le gustará a quién le gustará
pero experimenté con colores con flores
con bordados con distintos materiales
con cristales también con técnicas
tradicionales de bordado y me divertí
mucho A mi manera y al final a la gente
le gustó tuve mi revelación y por suerte
fue apreciada así lo hice con las
colecciones y me dije soy yo quien viste
a la gente no son los demás quienes me
dicen lo que tengo que hacer
[Música]
sabemos que el mundo de la moda puede
servir de encrucijada para todo tipo de
conexiones cree que la moda es capaz de
cambiar realmente las cosas
la moda puede cambiar las cosas la moda
allá en el camino a nuevas formas de
hacer las cosas a nuevas culturas
también está muy ligada la imagen de la
mujer que se proyecta en el espacio
público
sabemos que en el pasado la moda ha
liberado a las mujeres
por ejemplo vistiendo trajes masculinos
en el trabajo
o para sentirse más a gusto en la Esfera
pública y ahora la lucha cambia de forma
la moda sigue ayudándonos a ser más
libres
poder vestirme de hombre o de princesa
absolutamente una princesa o incluso
podría ser una princesa árabe sí
totalmente
[Música]